only a few can move outside the system
and some are friends some are enemies
sometimes you won't ever know hey Sara
mile
dangerous wild card but she's the best
hacker I know he can't get to places
they can't their security will detect
the intrusion but by then it will be too
late
do not use being a team
ready skirt genius still plates with
fire what the heck is up with our DNA
that makes us laugh blowing [ __ ] up it's
some primal mojo that's for sure
Geordi chin I fix it with principles to
change with the price you got to start
separating the morals from the moolah
this is what I have for you and say yeah
sticky bomb it sticks that is a terrible
plan
I love it that's me wait take a Iraq
ex-army military strategy to gang
warfare this vigilante that's some kind
of killer we're up against
you picked the fight Pierce let's play
it out
lucky Quinn rules Chicago's crime
syndicate with muscle and charm
experiences taught me not to be
manipulated not to back down
city of three little people you'd be
surprised a few you can trust
you